-As a magician... wizard...
-As a, as a wizard.
I felt like I could honestly
see dragons.
Life gives you lemonades.
No. Is that right?
-Lemons give you lemon--
-Lemons.
What is it?
-Hello. I'm George Robinson.
-I am Chinenye Ezeudu.
-I'm Ncuti.
-And I'm Kedar, and today...
We're gonna be making
a perfect cup of tea...
Whilst also talking
about identity.
There's nothing better
than a chat
over a cup of tea,
-is there?
-Trust.
Should we spill the tea?
Let's get stirring.
Ncuti Gatwa
is a Scottish-Rwandan actor
who's got
a lot of love to give,
but also is still
figuring things out.
How'd you describe yourself
in a sentence?
I'd say
Kedar Williams-Stirling
is still figuring it out.
Twenty six, bruv.
I've only just started.
I'm 45, man.
Don't you talk to me
about 26.
How would you describe me
and I'll do
how I would describe you.
Energetic, kind,
and bring a fantastic energy
into any room.
I would describe you
as being really funny
and nice to be around
and you're really talented
as well.
Look at you!
You're, like, cringing.
But it's all true.
The first word
that comes to my mind
is parents.
I don't know why.
Interesting.
And you've been growing up,
grown up in a few places,
so I guess that is quite
a rich upbringing
within itself.
Self is the first word
I think about
when I think about identity.
How you are as a person.
What you believe in,
what you stand for.
It's in The Matrix,
isn't it?
That idea
of residual self-image
of how
you perceive yourself.
I think it's simultaneously
what you think of yourself
inside yourself, but also,
how you present yourself
to others,
-if that make sense?
-Yeah.
Family. Family influence.
Mean a lot.
The experiences
that we go through
-shape our perspectives.
-Yeah.
Even listening to music.
I'm a completely
different person
when I'm listening
to pop music.
-I'm more fun.
-Yeah.
And when I'm listening
to rock music
I'm a different breed.
But those kind of things
just shape you.
And I think,
a lot of the times,
is the way that we try
and negotiate the world.
We build mechanisms
within ourselves
to tackle
certain situations.
We are the sum
of our experiences.
My parents, friends,
books, films, traveling.
The Harry Potter books,
-right?
-Fair.
Like, really,
really formed my identity
-as a little kid.
-As a magician.
-As a, as a wizard!
-Wizard.
I was just so obsessed
with anything fantastical.
Like that was on my mind,
was on when I was a kid.
Like, I felt like I could
honestly see dragons.
Really?
I hear it, I hear it.
So,
I just loved Harry Potter,
like anything fantastical.
Yeah. Especially with
our characters.
People expect your character
to be a dick, right?
But then you're just not.
Like, we're just playing
these characters
and playing these people
and we're just not them.
There's definitely
a conflict in terms of
for a character you'll use
a set of traits
that you have yourself
or there just naturally is
some overlap,
but takes real courage
is to push against that
and just be like,
no, no, no, I'm me.
I feel
it's hard to be yourself
in this day and age
with, like,
Instagram, Twitter,
people dictating what
the beauty standards are
and you just really
have to home in on yourself
-and be like, who am I?
-Yeah.
And that's, I think,
the hardest person
to be with is yourself.
Yeah. I think, obviously,
with my experience
I've lot of time
to think about who I am,
and what it means
to be George Robinson,
and not allow
other people's perceptions
of me affect how I act.
Think Steven Fry
said something
really interesting
to me on set.
He was like,
"I am not one thing."
"I am not just an actor,
I am all things."
I think there's a narrative
that's put on to us
as black males
and a sort of responsibility
that you don't
I don't even think realise
until you're a certain age
and you're aware
of more things
that weren't even
in your mindset
that you then kind of feel
part of in a way
that is actually not
anything to do with you...
-Right. Right.
-...as a being.
But yet, you're universal.
Your experience
in this world
is shaped
by this external thing,
which, of course,
then is part of you.
Because you are
experiencing this world
as a black person.
And then, I guess, also,
nobody ever knows you
really fully.
I don't really feel like
you ever
fully know yourself.
You're constantly learning
and constantly
experiencing things.
Think you co-switch
subconsciously.
For example, like Mumsy.
Me and Mum
have a great relationship,
but there's
a transparency there
that is still different
to my bedroom,
-know what I mean?
-Right.
It's not even
a conscious thing,
it's like a subconscious.
Just way of...
don't know
if that's a bad thing.
So therefore,
you saying about
the middle-aged white guy
who might be going
for whatever prejudices
and bestows them on to you
and then me coming to you
and chatting to you
about something.
You co-switching
between the two
is you just
kind of navigating
how to just be
in that space.
I don't know
if that is a bad thing.
'Cause I think, as humans,
we do that naturally
'cause that is just
what humans are.
We adapt and evolve.
Yeah. Yeah.
Just keep on brewing.
I love you so much.
You are so brilliant.
I would say be strong,
wait for life to happen
and the colours will change.
And you'll get stronger
as time goes by.
The stronger you are,
the more depth of flavour
you'll have.
If you want some acidity,
-go a bit of lemons...
-Yeah.
-Or ginger. Do that.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Chuck it in.
-Exactly.
Try experiment new things.
Life gives you lemonades.
No. Is that right?
-Lemons give you lemon--
-Lemons.
What is it?
You're a cup of tea, man.
Just enjoy it, man.